hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to siren head if you don't
know about siren head there's a
mysterious new creature that's wandering
around the dark corners of the Internet
I haven't heard much about siren head
until just recently as a mod for Fallout
now this game is part of a ps1 jam and I
don't know how much it's going to get
into who or what
siren head really is let's see what the
deal is Here I am again on my own my
like park maintenance no vehicles
allowed Pineridge hiking trail yeah it
seems like it's gonna end poorly that's
so big sorry I shouldn't be staring at
it but that's a big Sun all right
yeah eet yep it Eve
[Music]
and the sun's going down okay maybe I
should skadoodle from so siren had as
far as I know is a big old walking alarm
siren am I supposed to do nothing about
this weird bag in the bush
I suppose I'm supposed to do nothing
about the weird bag in the bush what am
i lazy that poop
Zep poop that better not be poop what is
that a hat a medkit I don't know I can't
tell this is that poop now it's probably
blood or rust or something like that
well that's no good well that's no good
at all
hello hello the good thing about siren
ed is I'm assuming I will be able to
hear him from a long way coming her it
he we siren what oh it's blood turns out
it was dried blood the whole time
oh you got blooded oh you got pulverized
what happened oh my goodness
is it gonna happen to me sir but no
specific oh I have to get back to the
truck now I was to be inspecting the
other
[Music]
okay my goodness
oh that's it oh that's that's all hey
whoo siren head what a siren I gotta do
a Google site on it what the [ __ ] oh my
goodness oh my goodness this is like a
new Slenderman oh dude that's like some
scary stories to tell in the dark kind
of stuff going on did this just crop up
like out of nowhere October 31st 2018 so
siren Eddie's been a thing for what this
game is old
what the [ __ ] when did that happen I
have to get back to a truck no but what
you might not know is you can actually
touch this buddy hello hello you can
just right up oh my god I can go right
past it
wait I need to go back into this because
siren ed is suddenly becoming a very
interesting thing to me examine my mouse
I wasn't even examining the right things
I was looking I didn't know that I could
zoom with my eyes I want to look at the
Sun my old forest service truck I really
should get it washed yeah it looks like
blood a hiker was reported missing I was
sent here to take a look around for them
hopefully they're not hurt yeah I'm
telling you that might be her they might
be real Hoyt whoa is that a warning
siren where could that be coming from
yeah yeah freaking Wonder it's a
backpack maybe it belongs to the missing
hiker but why leave it behind I don't
know man I don't know that poop scrap of
a shirt looks like there was a struggle
yeah no joke wee-ooh wee-ooh indeed more
strange scratch marks yeah
scratches seem to lead up here yeah yeah
yeah yeah they do what the hell is that
I should take a closer look maybe I
shouldn't maybe I shouldn't could that
be I have to get back to the truck now
I'm just gonna go Jesus Oh God screw
that so hard oh my god I hate that I
have to get back to the truck now yeah
you're right oh my god get back to the
truck now I was horribly disconcerting I
do not like that
[Music]
go go go go what was the way away what
was the screaming about I heard a
muffled scream who is the muffled
screams wait Han I'm gonna go back in
one more - this is fascinating to be
it's like a whole new creature and this
started back in 2018 why is this
suddenly researching now how did I never
hear about this I'm a dude that plays
scary games for like a living how did I
not know about this before
honey men don't know about this game
this is weird this is really weird
almost as weird as that head in the
corner
hi bud god the mouth hmm
yeah-hoo-hoo so big okay I just wanted
like talk to you I guess I didn't make
it I mean I didn't make it I definitely
didn't make it oh so siren it has been a
game for ages why suddenly now version 1
October 31st 2018 weird I'm Otis
interactive they've made other games
they made games I've played weird
ok so Trevor Henderson is the creator
that's what it said character of Trevor
Henderson was featured in a video game
of the same name
what
[Music]
[Applause]
that's horrifying
that's horrifying I think I remember
hearing about that that's horrifying in
one of trevor Henderson's post what
seems to be siren head is standing on
the side of a road in a suburb instead
of siren and having to sirens on set
like usual he is seen having a lamp head
which at first was very confusing but
after a while Trevor Henderson finally
released a fact sheet on siren head and
one of the facts state that has been
seen with different head arrangements
though it's unclear whether those are a
subspecies or if it's able to change its
head to better hide when hunting there
was another photo with the caption of
siren heads the caption has several
different siren headland creatures with
different colors this implies that there
are more than one siren head height this
creature will hide in forests who spot a
human once spotted the siren head will
stand still in groups of trees for weeks
at a time to finally run quickly at the
human and pick up the human to devour
them if a group of people comes the
siren head will eat one of the humans
and mimic their voice saying to come to
him people then proceeded to eat them
all if a siren head cannot find food for
long enough it will travel far but this
can also occur if a siren had seized
another siren head got there mating must
be horrifying the siren head when awake
will make snippets of music usually
sounding a bit like police sirens when
it gets a bit loud sometimes it will
make creaking like noises or alien
sounding noises when it's asleep it will
simply make white noise as its head
suggests it can make loud siren noises
Akhanda this creature is when mimicking
a voice it is loud when you hear a hey
guys come over here when travelling in a
force and you notice it's coming from
afar you know it's him the siren head
also seems to be able to pick up signals
as suggesting by some of the sounds it
makes heard in the siren head game
there's a story with 12 soldiers where
they met a siren head which started to
make siren noises as loud as it can
which caused 6 to have their brains
explode and the other half of the group
getting permanent hearing loss I don't
know if your brain can explode from a
sound but holy crap oh my god look at
this look at that look at the [ __ ]
last thing you see thank God it doesn't
have a dick look at this oh my
No oh my god no no no no don't look at
me with your ass hanging out no no thank
you
the last patient the [ __ ] is that
alright that's a something for another
day holy [ __ ] oh I see Trevor Henderson
they just make monsters oh I hate this
so no it's not even there I hate that
that so much god why is it not working
of course it's not working the one
picture I want it's to curse to look at
okay so Trevor Henderson definitely
makes some creepy look Trevor Henderson
is like a treasure trove of SCP
inspiration like oh my oh my god oh my
god Alper turbid or pepper Henderson
you've got an imagination on you oh my
god no thank you
oh my god oh my god oh god objects in
mirror closer than they appear
I don't know how I haven't heard of you
you make so much curse stuff Oh No thank
you now I can't believe that game led me
down the road of all this stuff but man
that's some creepy [ __ ] going on there
that's amazing that is really actually
amazing there's so much crazy stuff
going on here I can't really wrap my
head around it but yeah so I didn't know
that this response something more and I
can't believe that this has been around
this long and only recently blowing up
in addition to all of Trevor's stuff so
much potential for creepypasta so much
potential for scary games here I love it
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to know more about siren ed
or if you know more about siren ed say
so in the comments down below I keep
seeing my head down there in the corner
there but thank you everybody so much
for watching there's more scary stuff in
the description there's more scary stuff
in the suggested videos and yeah I would
not be surprised if more scary stuff of
trevor's comes out into the forefront
now because the flood gates have been
opened and there is no closing it for
siren ed it's just yeah so anyway thanks
again and as always I'll see you
in this video bye-bye
[Music]